when uh metoo was first breaking out I
had a lot of very famous friends
freaking out thinking I don't know
what's gonna Who's Gonna Come forward
from the hundred girls I was with who
you know just decides that they didn't
like what I did that night four years
ago and I'm screwed and they would have
been you know and they were sweating it
so I think the future of you know a
signed contract is not that uh you know
not that crazy
um but videos that people have
reputations sure and uh you know it's
it's discussed but by and large All
actors are crazy so you know what you're
getting into you know that's true
there's nutty people
um myself included you know it's just
it's a weird kind of uh profession to
pursue it's that it's it's an insane
profession to pursue it's impossible the
rejection is constant so you've got to
be that kind of person who Embraces
rejection
um
a lot of ego I mean because if you're
especially if you're on camera how do I
look how do I how am I perceived how
does the world perceive Maybe